tél
ça
côté mike et les soit conduit un grand
malade même la batmobile tient pas la
route comme cette bagnole
c'est pas parce que tu as un bolide et
des fuites moloch de batman le quart
[Applaudissements]
sortez le moindre set pagnol à fox ne
fasse de ça on en a fait du chemin
on voit enfin le bout dis pas de
conneries je vais traquer des criminels
jusqu'à les centres non c'est bon moi je
raccroche
quoi tu lâches les dates ans il est
temps qu'on soit des gentils mec
tu en connais beaucoup qui chanterait
cette chanson que vous intégrez une
nouvelle équipe vous bossez avec larmes
sans son capitaine larmes force c'est
high school music hall avec des fleuves
tel ce soit avec papy alors ses toiles
rigolo il y en a toujours
jusqu'à ce qu' on n'est plus une équipe
soudée ses salles
marcus quelqu'un cherche à le tuer je
voudrais te tuer moi je me méfie des
gens qui veulent pas le tuer mais moi
j'ai envie de le bouter merci on a capté
marcus tu as bien fait de venir
mais y'a pas plus sacré que la famille
alors je te laisse pas ton parc est seul
dans une mission suicide
une dernière fois la dernière
pas
oui
une sorte ces hélicos
aïe
c'est la voiture de ma femme non toi tu
prends l'entrée elle était au courant et
c'est toujours tout
[Musique]